nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
sur l'île de Java en Indonésie une ville
coule littéralement cette ville c'est
Jakarta l'actuel capital 11 millions
d'habitants l'une des villes les plus
peuplées d'Asie du Sud-Est elle est
aujourd'hui directement menée par la
montée des eaux qui s'accélère avec le
réchauffement climatique 40% de la
superficie de la ville se trouve déjà
sous le niveau de la mer en duplex on
retrouve Lucie berbet Lucie la situation
de Jakarta est si alarmante que le
gouvernement indonésien a pris une
décision radicale déplacée la capitale à
1500 km de là en créant une ville
nouvelle dont vous êtes allé visiter le
chantier
bon il faut s'imaginer c'est une ville
gigantesque de plus de 560 km², qui est
littéralement en train de sortir de
terre sur l'île de Bornéo dans le centre
de l'archipel indonésien cette ville
elle doit être construite sur une forêt
artificielle mais c'est bien l'idée même
de développer une ville ici sur l'île de
Bornéo qui inquiète les communautés
locales et les défenseurs de
l'environnement pourtant l'idée de
déplacer la capitale indonésienne elle
n'est pas nouvelle et elle est même
plutôt populaire dans le pays la ville
de Jakarta est une ville en sursis c'est
la ville qui coule le plus vite au monde
les quartiers du nord de la capitale les
quartiers côtiers ont même sombré de
plus de 2 mètres 50 c'est 10 dernières
années et les habitants là-bas font déjà
face aux conséquences concrètes de la
montée des eaux oui on va découvrir ça
dans le reportage que vous avez consacré
à Jakarta reportage tourné avec
Ulysse caillou on vous retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
mon objectif c'est de quitter Jakarta
avec ma famille pour nous installer plus
en hauteur mais pour l'instant je n'en
ai pas les moyens
[Musique]
même si on est bien conscient que
Jakarta est en train de couler
[Musique]
la vie de muhamadroni ne tient qu'à ce
mur de 5 mètres de haut et 32 km de long
qui évite au quartier pauvre du nord de
Jakarta d'être engloutis par l'océan
car la capitale indonésienne de 11
millions d'habitants bâtit sur un delta
subite aujourd'hui de plein fouet la
montée des eaux et se noie peu à peu
une situation aux conséquences déjà
dramatiques surtout en période de
mousson quand des pluies diluviennes
s'abattent sur Jakarta
[Applaudissements]
toute la ville de Jakarta est concernée
par ses inondations qui bouleverse la
vie des habitants
le centre
mais surtout les zones côtières
car ici le sol c'est déjà dangereusement
affaisser sous le niveau de la mer et
continue de s'enfoncer de 25 cm par an
le long de la côte
un naufrage qui s'explique par des
décennies passées à puiser de l'eau
directement dans les nappes phréatiques
les sols fragilisés par ces milliers de
forages ne peuvent plus soutenir le
poids de la ville
c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
ni a grandi dans ce bidonville de 10000
habitants au milieu d'un dédale de
ruelles qu'il connaît par cœur
venez par ici
c'est un raccourci pour aller voir le
mur
à 49 ans il a été l'un des premiers
témoins de la montée des eaux à Jakarta
aujourd'hui cet enfant du quartier peine
à reconnaître la plaine où il a grandi
beaucoup d'endroits où j'allais jouer
étant enfant ont disparu depuis la
construction du mur et les terres de
l'autre côté ont déjà été engloutis par
l'océan
Mohamed Rosny se s'étend sursis car la
digue érigée il y a 5 ans montre déjà
des faiblesses
des fissures que les habitants ont tenté
de colmater
en vain
l'eau gagne peu à peu du terrain
au début il n'y avait pas de fissure
elles sont apparues quelques mois plus
tard et de l'eau a commencé à
s'infiltrer
nous sommes inquiets quand on voit
l'état du mur on se dit qu'avec la forte
pression de l'océan le mur posséder à
tout instant et inondé tout le quartier
ça nous fait très peur
[Musique]
face au déclin de Jakarta les autorités
indonésiennes ont pris une décision
radicale et inédite
construire une nouvelle capitale de
toutes pièces ici sur l'île de Bornéo
poumonvert de l'Indonésie à 1500 km de
Jakarta
[Musique]
le chantier a déjà commencé
officiellement seul des forêts qui
servent aujourd'hui à l'industrie du
papier seront détruites
22000 ouvriers s'activent depuis des
mois un projet titanesque à 33 milliards
d'euros dont se félicite ce responsable
chargé de superviser les travaux
présente peu de risques de catastrophes
naturelles il y a peu de séismes ou
d'inondation contrairement à Jakarta
naturelles sont très vastes ici c'est
aussi une belle opportunité de
développement pour la région
[Musique]
et voici à quoi devrait ressembler la
future capitale
une ville aux allures futuristes aux
nombreuses zones boisées qui fait la
promotion des énergies vertes
elle doit abriter notamment le palais
présidentiel puis à terme près de 2
millions d'habitants d'ici 2035
essentiellement des fonctionnaires ou
des cadres
cette ville porte déjà un nom nous
sommes Tara archipel en indonésiens un
mot censé symbolisé l'unité du pays
[Musique]
mais pour faire sortir de terre cette
nouvelle capitale verte des milliers de
villageois autochtones vont devoir être
expulsés
vous voyez ici ils ont déjà commencé à
construire des bâtiments officiels
y a-t-il Dalia est né dans la région
elle observe chaque jour l'avancée des
travaux et ne supporte pas l'idée de
voir la nouvelle capitale empiéter sur
ces terres
on vit sur ces terres depuis très
longtemps quand il n'y avait pas encore
de route qu'il fallait passer par les
rivières pour se déplacer quand nos
villages n'avaient pas d'électricité et
maintenant on veut nous jeter dehors
pour laisser la place aux nouveaux
habitants
aux abords de ce village un système de
retenue d'eau pour approvisionner la
future capitale étant construction
en train de construire
parce que le chantier se trouve à
quelques mètres seulement des
habitations
80 familles vont être expulsées et
relogées à 200 km d'ici obligé
d'abandonner leur terres et leurs
racines
y a-t-il Dalia est loin d'être la seule
à s'indigner du projet
ici la colère gronde ces villageois
voyaient dans cette nouvelle capitale
une opportunité de développement et
d'emploi mais aujourd'hui bientôt
déloger il se sentent totalement
impuissants
et nos maisons vont être détruites ou
allons-nous aller à quoi va ressembler
la vie de nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants
on ne peut rien faire je suis désolé
mais cette nouvelle capitale ne nous
rend ni fier ni heureux au contraire
elle nous rend triste et anxieux
nous ne sommes pas opposés au
gouvernement nous les autochtones on ne
veut pas le combattre
on veut simplement qu'il nous écoute
à Bornéo le projet de futur capital
inquiète aussi les défenseurs de
l'environnement
à cause de l'exploitation d'huile de
palme les forêts sont déjà en proie à la
déforestation et des dizaines d'espèces
comme Laurent Houtan symbole de
l'Indonésie sont menacés d'extinction
les cultures intensives d'huile de palme
ont progressivement décimé leur habitat
à travers toute l'île de Bornéo
la nouvelle capitale s'annonce comme une
menace supplémentaire pour l'écosystème
de l'île déjà fragilisé
à 50 km des chantiers Agus Bay protège
cette mangrove depuis 23 ans ces
dernières années face à l'étalement
urbain il a vu sa surface diminuer peu à
peu et craint que le phénomène ne
s'accélère avec la nouvelle capitale
ici il y avait une mangrove maintenant
elle a été détruite c'est un port pour
le transport maritime
si les si important de préserver ses
forêts c'est parce qu'elles abritent des
espèces endémiques qu'on ne trouve que
sur l'île de Bornéo
c'est un groupe de singes
[Musique]
ne serait plus que 150 aujourd'hui dans
la région
et leur nombre ne cessent de diminuer
ces dernières années
aggus Bay redoute de voir leur habitat
se réduira encore avec l'arrivée en
masse de nouveaux habitants
le risque c'est qu'avec la forte
pression immobilière l'émancrove soit
détruite et transformé en
infrastructures ça peut réduire
drastiquement la surface de la forêt et
si les singes nazis ne trouve plus à
manger l'espèce va s'éteindre
cette nouvelle capitale qui doit sortir
de terre en pleine forêt
les habitants des quartiers pauvres de
Jakarta ne la verront jamais
moi madre ni le sait il ne fera pas
partie des personnes relogées
[Musique]
dans sa maison où il tient une petite
épicerie il vit toujours sous la menace
des inondations
alors pour réduire le risque qu'il a été
forcé de s'adapter
ici le sol était environ 80 cm plus bas
au moment des inondations
mais le père de famille se sait toujours
menacé malgré ses travaux en période de
mousson sa maison se retrouve toujours
inondée
j'ai toujours peur des inondations
surtout si le mur venait à céder
si les fissures continuent à s'agrandir
notre peur pourrait devenir réalité le
quartier pourrait être englouti en a
rien de temps
[Musique]
dans le nord de Jakarta une partie de ce
quartier a déjà été engloutie
comme cette mosquée
lentement dévorée par les eaux
[Musique]
avant j'étais heureux de vivre en bord
de mer de voir les vagues et de m'amuser
dans l'eau
mais dès que j'ai vu ce mur et la montée
des eaux
j'ai compris que ma survie ne tenait
plus qu'à cette digue
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je pense que ce n'est plus
possible pour nous de vivre ici parce
que le niveau de la mer continue sans
cesse de monter on ne peut que prendre
nos précautions et espérer que le
gouvernement prenne la mesure du
problème
[Musique]
la nouvelle capitale indonésienne
devrait être achevée en 2045
d'ici là un tiers de Jakarta pourrait
être déjà submergé
et on retrouve Lucie berbay Lucie on l'a
vu dans votre reportage les conséquences
de la montée des eaux sont déjà bien
visibles à Jakarta mais comment en
est-on arrivé là à ce tel point Jakarta
peut-elle encore être sauvé elle serait
réversible
le problème de Jakarta il est multiple
déjà il faut le rappeler la ville a été
construite sur un delta donc sur des
sols particulièrement instables mais la
raison principale c'est sans aucun doute
les milliers depuis illégaux qui ont été
construits à travers la ville et qui ont
servi aux habitants pendant des
décennies pour puiser l'eau directement
dans les nappes phréatiques c'est la
pratique aujourd'hui elles sont
quasiment à sec et elles peinent à se
régénérer à cause de la bétonisation des
sols à Jakarta pour autant vous
l'imaginez bien des solutions ont été
pensées pour sauver la capitale
indonésienne ou pour du moins tenter de
réduire les effets de la montée des eaux
l'une de ces solutions c'est le mur que
nous vous avons montré dans notre
reportage ce mur il fait partie d'un
projet encore plus grand qui doit
aboutir en 2027 à la création de
plusieurs digues et notamment à la
construction d'une île artificielle dans
la baie de Jakarta une île de 40 km²,
qui doit accueillir à terme une partie
de la population de la capitale mais ce
projet il est décrié par une partie
désurbanistes qui estiment qu'il ne
s'attaque pas aux problèmes de fond de
Jakarta c'est-à-dire l'affaissement des
sols et qui l'offre simplement une
solution temporaire une solution à court
terme pour sa population alors vous nous
avez aussi montré dans votre reportage
les travaux de la nouvelle capitale
quand doit-elle entrer en fonction
alors justement au lendemain de notre
tournage sur l'île de Bornéo le
président indonésien est venu rendre
visite aux ouvriers sur le chantier et
pendant cette visite il a rappelé
l'objectif principal la première
échéance de cette nouvelle capitale
c'est l'inauguration du palais
présidentiel qui doit avoir lieu des
l'été 2024 c'est dans un peine plus d'un
an alors d'ici là la capitale ne sera
pas terminée les travaux doivent se
poursuivre jusqu'en 2045 mais le
gouvernement se veut optimiste pour le
développement de cette capitale qu'il
n'imagine d'ailleurs pas uniquement
comme une capitale administrative il
veut vraiment en faire une mégapole à
part entière qui accueillera des
millions d'habitants des écoles des
hôpitaux même des terrains de football
c'est un sport particulièrement
populaire en Indonésie et ça le
président l'a bien compris puisqu'il
compte miser sur le sport pour
promouvoir la nouvelle capitale il s'est
pris à rêver publiquement d'organiser
les jeux olympiques de 2036 à nous
santara dans la nouvelle capitale
indonésienne alors pour le moment ce ne
sont que des mots mais ils montrent bien
l'ambition du gouvernement pour sa
future capitale merci beaucoup Lucie
berbès c'est la fin de ce magazine merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]